est arrivée telle une rock star à
montigny le bretonneux pedro miguel
pauleta ancien attaquant du paris
saint-germain de 2003 2008 est venue en
sciences délicat dans cette grande
surface
l'occasion pour l'aigle des açores au
109 buts avec le psg de retrouver ses
fans
c'est un plat 0
regardez tout ce b se portent à rester à
côté de moi c'est srdjan cernéenne que
ça continue depuis de 11 12 ans venus
comme ambassadeur d'une grande marque de
café portugais il a signé des
autographes et pris des photos pendant
plus d'une heure etc 600 supporters
présents certains n'ont pas hésité à
partir plus tôt du travail a patienté
dans la longue file d attente super
important quand on voit le joueur
emblématique était pauleta point vous
partir du psg c'est normal de venir à
cette séance de dédicaces ça fait du
monde pour un jour où 16 heures comme ça
où les gens travaillent
mais je pense que certains se libère
comme en l'occurrence mais bon on fait
une fois dans notre vie après c'est un
sacré souvenir des supporters
historiques ont ressorti des reliques du
passé
c'est quand même hein mon idole un
parisien
un vrai buteur j'ai pu déjà rencontré
quand j'étais petit le revend une
deuxième fois plus près c'est génial en
tant qu'abonné depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant vraiment pauleta le
symbole parisien quand même dans les
prochaines semaines pauleta continuera à
sillonner les centres commerciaux d'île
de france l'ancien footballeur pour
encore mesurer sa popularité